When the announcement came that the majority
of Conservative lawmakers DO have confidence
in Theresa May, her supporters could breathe
a sigh of relief.
But not everyone could share the joy.
About one third of may's own party voted against
her.
The prime minister's critics think she should
resign.
She cannot get her deal through....having
failed in her main policy, it would be constitutionally
normal for her to retire from the fray.
After weeks of speculation about how much
support May had from within the party, enough
letters were sent in to trigger a confidence
vote on her leadership.
Some conservative politicians are unhappy
with the Brexit deal she's struck with the
European Union.
But May warned that ousting her would only
delay or even stop progress.
But now that May has survived the vote she
is adamant that she will continue her mission.
We now need to get on with the job of delivering
Brexit for the British people and building
a better future for this country
Opposition politicians remain unconvinced
that Theresa May's Conservative government
is fit to cope.
This is the furthest stage in the Tory party
convulsing and arguing and bringing the bitterness
to the surface over the question of Europe.
It’s their problem, but it does impact upon
the nation at an absolutely crucial time of
crisis.
May's political survival can't stop the Brexit
clock ticking.
It's less than four months until the UK is
supposed
to
leave
the EU.